[Musique]
mes recherches portent sur l'amour de la
musique
je travaille en sociologue sur cette
relation particulière qui nous lie à la
musique et à nos goûts musicaux pour ma
part j'ai commencé à travailler il n'y a
plus de 20 ans sur le velvet underground
et ses relations avec andy warhol au
sein de la factory à de new york dans
les années 60 puis j'ai enquêté sur les
publics de la musique de l'est du jazz
et des musiques de jazz et de rock en
inde à calcutta notamment et depuis une
dizaine d'années je travaille sur les
publics de la musique classique de la
musique contemporaine avec entre autres
une enquête sur les ensemble
intercontemporain de pierre boulez alors
dans mes enquêtes
je pose souvent une question qui est
quel genre de musique écoutez-vous une
question simple à laquelle j'aimerais
que chacune et chacun d'entre vous
d'essayer de réfléchir la réponse que
vous pourriez me donner dans mes
enquêtes
la réponse la plus courante que
j'obtiens c'est moi j'écoute de tout je
vois au rire dans la salle que c'est la
parle à beaucoup de gens effectivement
alors cette réponse simple en réalité
recèle pas mal d'idées reçues
la première c'est qu'on est un petit peu
à part moi j'écoute de tout ça veut dire
écouter les autres ont peut-être des
goûts limité mais moi vous comprenez
c'est différent la deuxième idée c'est
que on veut montrer ainsi une forme
d'ouverture à la diversité musicale
alors la diversité cela peut s'entendre
différentes manières une diversité en
termes de genres musicaux d'une
diversité aussi en termes d'époque en
termes de lieu ou encore en termes
d'artistes différents au sein d'un même
genre
pour autant cette ouverture à la
diversité peut rester abstraite
si on ne la met pas concrètement en
oeuvre alors c'est pour ça que dans mes
enquêtes lorsque je discute avec les
personnes interrogées j'essaye d'en
savoir un petit peu plus et parfois il
ya un peu de difficulté à exprimer
concrètement cette ouverture et le
demande mais vous écoutez de tous
vraiment vous pouvez donner des exemples
alors gelé je n'ai pas ici mais c'est ça
s'affiche très bien donc vous tout le
monde voit les rolling stones vous
écoutez les rolling stones et tino rossi
vous écouter miles davis
et patrick sébastien
vous écoutez maitre gims hommes et
pierre boulez vraiment vous êtes sur la
temps évidemment des sourires ou des
rires dans la salle qui nous montrent
tout de suite que ces mélanges en
quelque sorte ne vont pas de soi ou dans
la conscience intuitivement et on se dit
qu'il ya une forme d'incongruités dans
cette juxtaposition alors on peut se
dire également aussi qu'on peut
connaître se sont appréciés on peut
écouter sans aimer mais si on écoute
sans aimer mais cela veut dire qu'on
exclue et que l'on n'est peut-être pas
si ouvert que ça et c'est pour ça qu'une
réponse commune aussi que j'obtiens
c'est moi j'écoute de tout sauf du rap
moi j'écoute de tout sauf du métal moi
j'écoute de tout sauf du classique
d'ailleurs à ce sujet la sncf a
expérimenté avec succès la diffusion de
musique classique dans les gares pour
faire fuir les groupes de jeunes qui
s'attarderait un peu trop longtemps et
finir vous que cela fonctionne et cela
marche aussi dans les centres
commerciaux en grande bretagne en suisse
alors le sociologue pierre bourdieu
disaient les goûts sont avant tout des
dégoûts et oui il est plus facile de se
définir sans doute parce que l'on n'aime
pas que parce que l'on aime et le dégoût
musicale finalement c'est le dégoût des
goûts musicaux des gens à qui on ne veut
pas ressembler les vieux peut-être pour
la musique classique mais ce n'est
qu'une hypothèse sociologique et 7
cette idée là en fait nous montre que
les goûts musicaux pas fonctionner comme
des frontières symboliques entre les
individus et les groupes sociaux
alors pourquoi continuer à croire que
nous sommes ouverts et pourquoi
continuer à faire croire aux autres que
nous sommes très ouverts en matière de
musique une raison essentielle tient à
notre croyance on a la liberté de nos
choix
en fait nous avons une conception assez
romantique de l'amour de la musique
c'est un type d'amour qui ressemble à
celui qui nous unit à notre amoureux
notre amoureuse un amour sans contrainte
sans nécessiter un amour de pure liberté
qui repose sur la passion et cet amour
de la musique qui construit nos goûts
musicaux musicaux contribuer à créer
également notre personnalité notre
identité personnelle et nous y tenons
fermement la rochefoucauld des est déjà
dense et maxime que nous tenons plus à
nos goûts qu'à nos opinions
c'est à dire que nous c'est donc plus
facilement sur nos opinions que sur nos
goûts il ya donc une forme
d'identification personnelle à travers
les goûts musicaux et l'adhésion à la
musique peut être très forte
alors elle est en particulier très forte
chez les plus jeunes qui peuvent aimer
la musique de manière passionnée mais
évidemment cette adhésion à la musique
se diffuse aussi dans la société et donc
dans nos nombreuses classes d'âge
mais chez les plus jeunes ça va aller de
pair par exemple avec un style
vestimentaire qui est adapté adéquate
avec le goût musical si on pense à la
musique funk au rap ou métal aux
gothiques et c'est alors on aboutit
évidemment à une contradiction puisque
d'un côté on va afficher une ouverture
aux goûts musicaux les plus divers et de
l'autre côté on va se définir par un
nombre restreint de genres musicaux
un nombre restreint voire même un genre
unique qui va contribuer à nous définir
personnellement alors sur 7 sur cette
idée de la définition de soi et bien
pour résoudre cette contradiction entre
définition de soi et ouverture il faut
comprendre que nous conservons les goûts
musicaux que nous avons forgé pendant
notre jeunesse
j'ai montré dans mes travaux par exemple
que l'on forge son goût musical entre 15
et 25 ans et qu'ensuite on continue à
conserver le même autrement dit si on a
découvert le jazz à 20 ans on va
continuer à l'aimer à 60 alors je vais
vous montrer un graphique
le voici l'âge médian des publics alors
sur ce graphique
j'ai mis deux enquêtes du ministère de
la culture de 1981 et 88 en bleu et
rouge
et j'ai ajouté une troisième colonne
orange qui est ma propre enquête sur les
publics de la musique classique en 2014
lorsque vous voyez c'est que d'abord
l'âge médian des publics est plus élevé
pour la musique classique et l'opéra que
pour le jazz qui lui même plus élevé que
pour le rock
alors ça c'est un premier élément peut
être assez connu le deuxième qui est
moins connu est plus intéressant c'est
que cet âge médian augmente avec le
temps
c'est à dire qu'on voit qu'entre 80 et
2008 tous les publics de tous les genres
musicaux ont vieilli et on a bien comme
ça une succession des générations qui
correspond à la succession des genres
musicaux dans l'histoire de la musique
alors est-ce à dire que il n'ya pas de
jeunes amateurs de musique classique de
jazz ou d'opéra bien en entendu non il
ne s'agit pas d'un déterminisme strict
mais de contraintes
donc on peut trouver ces jeunes amateurs
et dans mes enquêtes mais j'ai pu
montrer que ces jeunes amateurs de
musique classique présente des
caractéristiques assez distinctes id
ils ont notamment fréquenté le
conservatoire pendant assez longtemps
plusieurs années et ils ont bénéficié de
ce que les sociologues appellent une
socialisation musical précoce est
suffisamment longue et intense pour
contrebalancer les effets de la
diffusion massive des musiques
populaires sur les médias de masse ou
sur internet
si vous regardez par exemple le tube de
l'été 2010 est des spas sitôt a dépassé
les 4 milliards de vues sur youtube
donc c'est pas fort smith forcément
d'une très grande diversité
alors est-ce à dire pour autant que le
l'ouverture au goût musical d'autrui
serait réservé à ces enfants qui ont
bénéficié du conservatoire et que de
manière générale ce ne serait qu'une
qu'une illusion
je ne le pense je ne le pense pas parce
dans cette dans cette optique dans cette
optique là eh bien il faut tenir compte
d'un autre fait de notre croyance qui
est celle de la liberté de nos choix
précisément nous sommes peut-être pas
aussi libre que nous le pensons dans nos
choix musicaux nous aimons croire que
nous sommes très ouverts et sans doute
en raison du fait que les genres
musicaux sont aujourd'hui très
facilement accessible grâce au numérique
il ya internet sur deezer spotify ou
youtube
n'importe qui peut écoutez l'intégral de
maitre gims et l'intégrale de pierre
boulez et instantanément
évidemment ce n'est pas tout à fait ce
que nous faisons tous les jours mais
nous aimons croire aussi une deuxième
chose qui est peut-être plus importante
celle égale dignité de toutes ses formes
musicales c'est à dire l'idée qu'elles
ont toutes la même valeur et que nous
sommes parvenus à une sorte de
démocratie des goûts musicaux
chacun fait ce qu'il veut cette croyance
en réalité n'est pas partagé par tout le
monde au sein de la société
elle est en fait réservé plutôt réservé
aux classes moyennes et supérieures
c'est tenir aux catégories les plus
diplômés et peut-être justement à ces
catégories qui ont bénéficié d'une
éducation musicale de la fréquentation
du conservatoire ou d'une ouverture à la
sensibilité à diverses formes de de
musique
à tel point que l'on a les sociologues
de la culture disent aujourd'hui que
l'ouverture à la diversité musicale
c'est devenu le nouveau signe distinctif
des élites moderne
autrement dit pour être membre de
l'élite moderne il faut à la fois à
connaître ses classiques et en même
temps être très ouverts à la nouveauté
on serait ainsi passé d'une distinction
qui passait par l'exclusion à une
distinction par l'ouverture pour autant
dans nos comportements observables de
consommation de musique
nous continuons à considérer que nos
goûts musicaux sont les meilleurs c'est
normal ce sont les nôtres donc ce sont
elles sont les meilleures
alors cela et on dit il faut tenir
compte du fait que notre rapport à la
culture a profondément changé au cours
des dernières décennies et ce en raison
précisément d'internet et des
technologies numériques qui nous
permettent d'avoir accès techniquement
très facilement à des formes que musical
culturel très diverses et très variée et
en raison également de la montée de la
globalisation culturelle
c'est à dire la mise en contact
généralisée de toutes les cultures du
monde et aujourd'hui l'idée qui a
prévalu jusqu'à lors d' une stricte
hiérarchie des goûts musicaux
une hiérarchie au sommet de laquelle se
trouverait la musique classique
occidentale et l'idée d'une définition
unique du bon goût musical nous sont
aujourd'hui à peu près insupportable
dénigrer les musiques populaires
mépriser les musiques venues d'ailleurs
ce sont des attitudes que nous
n'acceptons plus vraiment autrement dit
nous voulons sincèrement être ouvert aux
musiques des autres nous voulons
sincèrement faire preuve d'ouverture et
de tolérance
mais cela passe d'abord par reconnaître
que cette ouverture ne va pas de soi
qu'elle n'est pas si facile et qu'il ne
suffit pas de la proclamer
pour la faire exister sinon eh bien nous
aurions affaire à une sorte d'hypocrisie
sociale qui consisterait à afficher une
tolérance de façade tout en continuant à
opérer des distinctions des sélections
est alors et à distinguer entre ce qui
relève du bon goût selon nous et ce qui
n'en relève pas alors bien évidemment
cette volonté de d'ouverture
et des données de tolérance ubf demander
comment faire pour la rendre plus
effectives et bien on peut imaginer que
la clé réside dans la démocratisation
précisément de l'éducation musicale et
artistique
c'est à dire qu'il faut accepter l'idée
que l'on doit diffuser pour toutes les
catégories de la population mais surtout
évidemment pour les plus jeunes
cet accès à une éducation musicale
diversifiée où l'on pourrait avoir accès
justement des formes musicales plus
exigeante où différentes
en tout cas différente de celle qui
passe simplement sur les réseaux sociaux
les sites de partage de vidéos ou sur
les plateformes de streaming d'aller un
petit peu plus loin grâce à s'éduquer
cette éducation musicale et artistique
qui ne serait plus réservée comme c'est
le cas encore trop souvent aujourd'hui
aux catégories les plus favorisées
alors à ce moment-là les hiérarchies
culturelles dont on parle est le mépris
des musiques populaires
la dictature du bon goût et du monopole
du bon goût pourront appartenir au passé
autrement dit nous avons encore quelques
efforts à fournir
alors après y avoir réfléchi plus
attentivement j'ai envie de vous poser à
nouveau la question et vous vous écoutez
de tous vraiment je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]